Hey hey everybody hey hey hey Terry
Griffin once again welcome back to
riffin with Griffin and I'm really
excited to have this person on the
podcast I want to thank everybody for
all your love and support and and people
sending in themed songs and all that and
I got another good one today this one
might be it I say that every week but
this one might be the one but before I
do that let me introduce my friend we
were on a diet appear together one of my
favorite people in the whole wide world
the beautiful and talented Brianne Howie
everybody look at you so I know you
don't watch my podcast cuz you already
told me this on the way over all right
so this is what I do every week I have
like you know I try to I'm looking for
the perfect theme song right so this is
uh this is a new one sent in by the
talented Brandon Horne and let's see
what Brandon has for us today
[Music]
[Music]
I don't think they use my voice Oh like
we're at a pool somewhere drinks we're
like we're in Vegas okay
Vegas Burbank you know thank you Thank
You Brandon that's it okay all right oh
yeah that was a club banger right there
from the great Brandon Horne thank you
very much so here you are finally Hey so
I'm so excited because I watch your show
so nice she's a Rance on the show the
passage yes and you are the Edouard on
that show and I had to do an interview
stop yes I did an interview where they
surprised me no like let's play these
games we're gonna put vampires on the
screen and you guess who they are and
Edward came up and I had no clue what
his name was luckily all the pictures
after that didn't work and never showed
up so I just pretended I never saw him
but he's like that's like he's the hot
vampire yeah and I know Bella you know
you're on your caught up well yeah you
are but I do watch it cuz I'm big on the
vampire genre I I read I've actually I
did read all the Twilight books I know
it seems crazy but I read all the John
Rizzo like I've read the passage oh is
that a book yeah to trilogy now I'm in
it they're they're amazing I'm gonna
read that one yeah and I love how the
difference is in like a different
vampire you into the vampire lore at all
yeah a little bit I mean we made it our
own
I mean I'm into like the perfecting the
human race I liked that part oh you mean
like so on the show how they're like
they use this they're trying to use this
vampire virus to like get rid of disease
and all this kind of stuff in this part
of the mythology where isn't that why
vampires wanting to eat everyone because
they want to turn everyone else into a
vampire because they think we're perfect
and you're all imperfect not part of the
Lord I don't think so vampires are just
blood sucking and you play very well so
it's so weird for me to like just
because every week I'm going I'm scared
of you but I'm like I get lost in it you
know but the lore on this one was
different because it's like I I never
seen it like this is very different in
terms of like you know there it's not
the normal vampire stuff other than like
they can't be in the Sun right it's very
scientific yeah it's like I think it's
it's the most realistic way possible we
could have vampires well other than the
fact that it was started by we don't
know where that originally that the 200
year old Bolivian yeah yeah yeah it
starts there yeah we don't know what
happened there but then everything after
that they're trying to like merge
science and sci-fi well that's is the
part I like about it a lot yeah and I
love the little girl on the show - yeah
she's great she's amazing she's usually
child actors are like they were either
really fantastic he's really really
fantastic you're great on it though it's
like ever we have a great cast rain
everyone's amazing when we first got it
you're kind of like I don't know these
are kind of interesting choices and it
all is working well what did you think
when you first like got the part when
you first like even saw like yeah like
hey there's this vampire thing Deegan I
like googled the book my character was a
guy beforehand so I was like okay that's
cool I respect the changes and then my
audition scenes were super interesting
and had nothing you do a thing a vampire
so it was all I was just auditioning as
a human yeah well I mean you're
auditioning as a human okay dog today
after they show I want to just be a
human a lot of the stuff that you're
doing on the show is very you know lot
of backstory stuff which I love yeah
because you're a killer on the show you
killed your mom
and your dad yeah you know me so that
you know you come you strong woman but
at the same time you're in death row and
they take you out of death row and put
you in this program to turn you into a
vampire to help a fight disease so they
have good intentions but it all fell
apart
exactly exactly so I know so like that's
what I like about the show I really like
that part of the show you know but I
also like the interactions and all that
kind of stuff
we're backstories help kind of tie it
all in everybody's connected it gives
some humanity to the vampires like I
think no one expected to be rooting for
them and now some people are like I know
I kind of want them a hundred percent
it's called having like empathy and for
our jars I think when you're playing a
villain you can't look at them like that
you have to be like you have to fully
see their point of view Wow and that's
why you play it and I love standing I
don't even get why everyone hates him
okay just this one of these crazy
actresses oh my god okay here all day
yeah that's yeah that's a crazy oh yeah
I mean yes everyone's rooting though for
Brad and Amy them to be safe and okay
and when but but see even I guess I see
what you're saying because the vampires
what choice did they have they were they
returned what I'm exactly yeah but then
everyone else around them is a part of
this like monster you know yeah they did
something bad even the main guy what's
what you know what's his name Brad right
Brad yeah yeah yeah and I was dark he
yeah what he was everything he did to
get like you know it's all the gray area
I think it's kind of what the show is
about but you're still a monster yeah
but if I've already been injected you
got to embrace your situation now I'm
living for the rest of eternity what am
I gonna do with it
and I like how they made it it's so
funny to me that they made it were like
you know the people before you that got
turned they didn't look normal okay so
we did a version of the pilot where I
did not look like that whatsoever why
would you want to waste this I was bald
I had no eyebrows there were no veins
but it was pale and and just no hey I
looked like a goblin like I look like
what's played the character in Lord of
the Rings oh my god
yes I've looked I'll send you a picture
later oh I got a suit then we reshot all
of that I'm a few months later I'm sure
I'm sure they were like we just got a
ugly G why would we hire just get
someone that already looks like a Gollum
why we wouldn't make any sense you know
I couldn't believe I agreed to it I like
signed my life away that way and I'm so
happy changes it's a super hit it's
going well yeah knock on wood no it's
gonna cut I'm sure it's gonna get picked
up I think we're okay
after the response is good people are
watching this last episode really ticked
me off as a as of this recording the
last episode was like her eyes changed
you know and I was like what's happening
and then it just went off you know the
credits came on because I watch the show
on Hulu shout-out to them so I don't
have to watch commercials yeah so that's
I hope it stays on there cuz it's great
cuz I hate I hate commercials now yeah
yeah but I have to like no we have to
watch it live to tweet with it and the
commercials really take you out of it
yeah oh you tweet you live tweets on
Mondays right and this episode will come
out on a Monday so that's actually
perfect it's our finale oh oh if it
happens to come out next month
when is your finale next Monday next
Monday oh this episode is gonna come out
next Monday yeah the finale to someone
as you're watching this watched
listening and watching tonight the
finale of passage they're combining 9
and 10
I don't do I have no idea I don't know
that's a bad thing oh this coming back
to someone they're like why would it be
a bad thing and I was like I don't know
maybe just want to get it over
I hate this business it's terrible I
hate this business it's wrong yeah even
like okay so by the way how we met
actually the the two of us met at an
audition I was walking in to audition
for a diner here and I saw you sitting
there and I was like oh look at this
beautiful creature right here you were
just and then you would just you know
you like I'm sure you know since you
were 13 years old every guy is just
hitting on you forever
and just like all we constantly can't
have a regular conversation what a guy
since 13 everything's been like so
what's up girl you like so I star you
and I was like oh yeah and I remember I
told you I said you're gonna get it you
did I'm gonna get this part and you're
gonna be a star did you said all of
those things yeah and then you were
looking at me like oh now you jinxed it
now I'm not gonna get this look and I
love this role and I love this show and
this [ __ ] just you did look at me all
funky and you got it and then we were so
happy to see each other at the table I
um did you ever go did you ever won't
have a chance to go out for Cassie at
all are you always how I went in oh you
went out forecast
initially yeah yeah and then they then I
got the callback for cat whatever the
girl's name was my name hold on hold on
cat no no was it hey hey hey hey yeah I
I don't know what happened I don't know
why I didn't bring you back cuz of
Exorcist nobody they could if they would
have season two I know I could have
committed to you and then you wouldn't
have done that
no you still part was I'm dying up here
such a big cast Exorcist was smaller I
think there was more it was more working
for me to grow yeah wow you're like the
horror movie
what happened you're on next will you
possessed him it because I never got a
chance to see any oh you I was depressed
not possessed they wanted you to think I
was the possessed one but I was really
just like really a lot of attitude and
was depressed why are you always now I
don't know you tell me I don't know how
I'm perceived out there
you're always damaged boy but before I'm
dying up here you know let's get your
origin story like we're from Pasadena LA
cañada Pasadena well you're from
Pasadena yeah why I thought it's gonna
be more like something more exotic
we're Arkansas Arkansas super exotic
rags-to-riches Sacred Heart you went to
Sacred Heart you know I went to Daniel
Murphy than you it was a Catholic school
that was one of our sister schools it
was in the mid Wilshire area it's closed
down said okay I remember cuz you grew
up around here yeah I grew up in LA I'm
from LA also yeah like lo la jolla high
school you do draw like all the dances
we do all the dances together also okay
so you went to Catholic school yeah I
mean before that I went to the schools
in LA can Yatta
what is your Catholic family saying
about all your devil my grandma hates it
so much it makes her so upset it starts
to hurt my feelings and I'm like Jemima
I'm just working let's just be happy I
have a job and it's not no she can't
stand it I was when you go to Grandma's
does she bring out the holy water my
grandma gives me holy water in old
mouthwashes she she pours out the
mouthwash but just then when I put it on
it just as like I'm putting Listerine on
myself she I in the last episode that
aired on Monday I'm smiling a lot in the
diner scene and she was so happy she was
it was the first yeah she was like
you're smiling and you look
happy and healthy and secure yeah she
wants me to just do like a lifetime show
excuse like you got to look pretty you
get the guy shows you're crying in a
bathtub washing the like watching the
abuse off of you that's all every life
[Laughter]
but okay so you alright so you go to
Catholic school okay did you know you
wanted to be an actress when you're in
Catholic school no I mean I did all the
plays but only because I didn't make any
teams
I liked odd to audition for words I like
try it out for all the sports teams and
just it didn't work so you didn't do
that up then what did you do then I had
tried out for a comedy Sportz The Improv
team really and I made it that is so
hilarious were you a late bloomer like
were you always like this fine or when
did it happen like 2000 high school
doesn't count as late okay so you were a
mean girl I see oh not at all my school
was super small everybody was friends
they're like 90 people per grade I loved
it okay yeah I think uh I think it's uh
what do you think about all girls
schools I love it I would if I had a
daughter I would send her there yeah I
was reading to think about this about
like I think all girl environment is
it's better for girls but I don't think
all boy environments good for boys they
need to be around women to learn how to
like normal life it's a normal life but
women I think it's great cuz then they
get to shine because you need them away
you need the boys away yes I do I think
if I had stayed at the school I was at
in LA cañada which was co-ed I don't
think I would have done comedy sports
cuz that takes a lot of courage and it's
kind of a great you have to really put
yourself out there and shoot exactly so
you did the cut so comedy sports what
does that even mean it does everyone not
call it that no it's just the high
school improv okay but you call it calm
okay it was called comedy sports the
Nerds feel better you're doing
sporks yeah we what did we say we would
compete for applause not fur trophies or
something it rhymed though I don't know
so did you follow I did love it I loved
it so you that's where I met my closest
friends I'm still friends with all of
them so yeah that's great yeah it was a
nice community that's so mean networks
are network you know it was great it was
so fun and then that's how then I
started doing plays then that started
that was fun and I loved it it was going
well I knew I wanted to go to college in
New York so I kind of thought if I could
get into NY use acting Department than
maybe in high school you knew you were
like I want to do this for a living
ah yes and no I mean no like no one in
my I'm not surrounded by people who are
in the industry like I didn't grow up
with any of that so I didn't really take
it as like a viable option you know what
that is it's from living in LA
like when we lit when you're from LA and
you're born in LA it feels more like a
pipe dream yeah where I'm like that's
not really a path I'm gonna go I don't
even know how you do that but then I
don't know I love doing theater so then
and I Love New York so much so I was
like if I could get into NYU use
department then maybe this is the real
deal
Wow so but were you like leading lady in
in their high school plays I was Alice
and Alice in Wonderland of course she's
a little late now so you uh you were
Alison oh my gosh so you were my was
also putting you were you the most
popular chick in school time no I can't
sing or dance when the musicals came
they would just shove me in the back and
let me like sashay off right left right
legs like to this day I'm still scarred
from that I hate musicals is that why
you didn't do like cheerleading or
anything like yeah I'm not
I can't I'd that's why I didn't make any
sports team it's like I tried and tried
and sports teams did you go out for
volleyball tennis basketball then I even
tried saxophone not that that's you into
the musical capacity and just not none
of it panda terrible I don't know why I
don't know I think Bill Clinton like did
it on TV
Bill Clinton no not a crush I was too
little but he was very popular okay so
you saw that you're like I want to do
that yeah okay so you Alice in
Wonderland and then what else were you
what else did we do we did weird plays
like we did Trojan women which would I
think I was just in the Greek chorus and
we always it was always female cast you
didn't you didn't like have males from
other boys you could practice after
school okay that's pretty dope yeah I
wish I would have done that it's great
oh man yeah okay so then you wanted to
go to NYU when did you want to go to my
you wouldn't when when in the process in
your junior year you were like oh I
think we went to New York and I know
even sooner than that I think the first
time I went to New York I was like this
is where I want to be oh wow you look so
how long were you near so you went you
got it oh yeah got in I had to minor in
child psychology cuz my mom was like I'm
not paying this life here just study
theater no I liked that it's interesting
I liked it shout out to mom yeah yeah
and then then I kind of started doing
the student film so my my roommates at
NYU who are still some of my closest
friends were these girls in the film
Department and they started putting me
in their stuff right right and then I
was like this is amazing and then I kind
of just kept doing it yeah and you'd
never thought pretty much I was able to
graduate with a good real cuz I did so
many work you turned out not bad out of
feel like you ever look at him now and
be like oh my god I can't believe I yeah
that's okay at the time you first do
something you think like I was so good
at that all my toys giving everyone the
DVD VHS tapes so you okay so then what
was your first like you graduated I
graduated an agent right away I got with
untitled who I'm still in with her my
management they sent me out my first
appointment which was nine or two and
now get out it I went in for girl in
greens my first ever like real audition
and I booked a better role
I booked Stacey oh wow it was yeah I
went from girl in green these days yes
it was a tart late bloomer late bloomer
like you were your freshman year you
were like I've already bloomed Stacey my
scene was bidding on this guy I had an
option to have a date with him and then
we like made out in the backseat Wow
you've been like doing like love scenes
from job huh pretty much is that like a
thing is they never bother you or like
you to put how do you prepare your
lesson I ended up playing like then a
handful of lesbians along the way which
I really liked footage of that was like
an ABC Family yes it's called twisted
yeah it was great so you did okay so
after Stacey after Stacey them where I
do then I did like a handful I mean my
trajectory really kind of has been like
I started out with like one line and
then
- and then three like I didn't I didn't
some people skip these steps and I don't
know how I'll just start getting like
recurring roles or leading roles right
away well there's no there's no right or
wrong way no yeah and mine was really
just kind of you've got a great
trajectory now that I think about it
like like you know yeah because after
you did that role but you did do some
I've done a it did like weird like
Criminal Minds and NCIS and y5o I've
done all those and I did like then the
twisted the ABC Family show is my first
big recurring I think that's when I quit
my side job maybe yeah in New York not
in New York no so right after NYU I
moved back to Oh gotcha gotcha yeah and
the work was here your waitress at where
no I was I worked at agent provocateur
oh you were like I am gonna be a big
time worker I was a waitress though in
New York and stuff like I would do
cocktail waitress and I worked for an
acupuncturist oh wow I wanted a hair
salon you catering yeah I've always done
it this is all help like you know yeah
like I was out I think it's cool when
you're out in the world and it sees you
- you have a you're out in the world
before you so you start really working
or auditions you have stuff to bring to
the table
yeah so you did twisted that was ABC
Family and you were like recurring on
there I recurred on that that was like a
high school drama Denise Richards played
my stepmom oh wow
and now she's on Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills which you don't do
housewives no I don't I just don't
understand like we'll admit what it
means to me when I watch those kind of
shows it just is like it's really about
men that make bad decisions in women
because they married these monsters
they're monsters v kelsey Grammer's wife
was on Beverly Hills and he started
having an affair and wanted to distract
his wife so he signed her up for the
show oh my and then did I know I know
what yeah it's crazy that's how you
having an affair
yeah well work cuz and she was
distracted started making some money and
he's like I gotta go
he did he left yeah oh you watch those
shows yeah this is that your guilty
pleasure for sure
you know I know we have a mutual guilty
pleasure 90-day fiance the government
shutdown was the worst thing never
happen because it delayed our show I did
that show infuriates me because because
these are I know I'm like what are you
doing why are you that there's just
nothing logical happening in any scene
with any person at any point and then
like the families hate each other like
I'm still knee-deep into that other
season with like Nicole and as in having
nipples on all the seasons though that
one's really heartbreaking she's not a
kid it's dark it's really dark there
often and when he took her on the hike I
was like this isn't a match take the fat
chick on a hike what do you I don't know
like does he not have other people he
could take advantage I don't know why
he's so invested in her in particular as
he's put in so much time at this part I
don't know I don't know I just I just
don't I think they might have their own
Oh sometimes it feels gross I know but
the really gross thing about it is the
fact that like when you watch that show
we always feel like the hot couples are
supposed to make it and then we have
this kind of like like angry reaction to
like the fat person or the old guy and
we're like what are you doing that you
don't deserve it's weird how I think
they're exploiting those type of people
they are for sure but like because all
the hot couples are just as bad who are
the hot couples though there's always
one hot person that it's never - okay
there's - okay what about the the model
that's in Miami the Colombian model oh
what's her face with Russ Russ the
couple yeah if we're talking about this
cuz they were rocky free right well she
had to live in Oklahoma that's the other
thing everyone assumes America is all
the same all across the board they don't
know that if you're going to Tulsa or
like
what tallahassee is like or even in LA
true you know enemy like if you're in
Reseda or it's not now you see the chick
who went to Las Vegas no I haven't seen
so disappointed so incredibly
disappointed how about the words she
gets there and he's got a roommate and
there's roaches and you have to walk
through the room mate oh you're from
walk through the roommates room to get
out to play yeah they're still together
yeah I know but they were really young
and like met when he was studying abroad
or something like some of them kind of
our most of the ones I think that we
always think they're gonna make it yeah
a pile of rust met her yeah in Colombia
like on vacation or what about the
Dominican one where the two families
hate each other I my god everyone on
that in that is stupid okay
I know River like rivers the brother
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay so you're on twisted okay yeah so
we did twisted my first kiss no no no
this was ABC Family oh so you were
lesbian on ABC Family yeah which is
crazy there's my first yeah lesbian
wrong but of course your lipstick in
that one yes and he said something else
the other one was too right um yeah
always kind of yeah I don't know yeah
that's that's that's how they do it they
don't want it to be real
yeah Network yes okay so you and you did
reoccurring you're the reoccurring yeah
and then I would do like I did like
playing house you ever watch that show I
love those girls um I don't know yeah
and now for ID I got to basically quit
my side jobs and kind of keep going
there would be like a few months in
between would be terrifying and to be
like oh my god
just like everybody else yeah what are
we doing but that was the moment you
liked working actress yeah yeah even
though before that you were but you
still like I still got to keep this job
yes and I worked at the Hollywood Bowl
doing nights then that was like my night
job and that was fun and then I was free
during the day but the moment that you
were like I'm a working actress yeah
what was that like um what was that like
it was great I mean I remember I mean
it's scary because that is a pretty big
leap to take cuz you don't totally know
what's gonna happen
that's like alekum sitting when you quit
your job was that a motorbike should I
do this of course of course but luckily
I knew them and they're like you need to
come back yeah so and just out of
stubbornness I probably wouldn't ever
have gone back but it was okay and I
didn't need to I'm gonna make it yeah
you know I have to yeah so you did to it
after twisted wouldn't what was after
that what cuz didn't you do when him did
when did you do that MTV show cuz that
was the one that was right before we
didn't you do what you on that like were
your models the models show that ways
that was a really specific show that
never aired in the US for Comedy Central
UK oh wow but that was your
international it was cool like it was a
multicam which is a whole different
experience yeah yeah I hate it yeah it's
like a cool skill I think to have as an
actor especially in the beginning
because it there's so much of it yeah
yeah yeah or yeah I don't know my
manager was like you need to oh this is
yes she was like you need to take a
multicam class because you're right for
a lot of those things and you you could
you could be right for them yeah you did
you just took a claim to be the hot wife
with the fat husband on a multicam can't
wait now you're too young for that now
I'm saying I hope ten more years you're
gonna be that you're gonna be that hot
forties mom not a bad gig you want to
shoot in LA you know you're our schedule
when kids come in to play
oh that's great yeah so you did that how
did you have to go to UK yeah that's why
the job was so cool I love the people I
got to work with and we got to shoot in
London Wow look at you you'd lived in
London for two years no for like two and
months oh oh god you got you sit you up
did the live shows he was like twelve
ten episodes yeah yeah just ten weeks
that was there must have been enough
money where you were like I'll do that
yeah for sure okay so then because
that's when that's when oh I'm dying up
here audition came yeah I guess so if
you remember that I do it cuz you were
just tell me you were just doing there
you were talking about having to go back
yes that's right yeah oh good memory
yeah because we could think about that
was crazy about him dying up here it was
like a it was like it was a decade
process it felt because like we did the
pilot in November of 2015
yeah but we booked a part say two months
three months before that yes yeah I
remember Andrew Santino saying he could
have had a child in between yeah so much
time was passing yeah so we did that and
then we and then like it wasn't a year
before we did the next season you know
and that's not they they didn't wait did
you I didn't do a season two at all oh
that sucks
but you so you got him down up here you
did that that was great I loved but I
think that I'm dying appear like was was
like it made you a serious actress at
that point cuz that's a really elevated
show yeah well like it was quit school
to start getting to do cable um and to
get to work with super experienced
people like all of you guys I got for me
that was cool especially cuz you guys
were recognizable and I knew who you
guys were and it was cool it was
interesting so would you think of that
it was it was so challenging yeah but at
the same time I thought comedy actually
I realized that drama is easier than
comedy absolutely yeah I agree
not everybody could you comment yes I
rely realize like you know just I
realized that I'm gonna be funny even if
it's like in a serious moment
I just I have the humor so I'm gonna
bring levity to something serious but to
bring like you know humor to something
that's supposed to be humorous yeah it
depends on just so many different levels
it doesn't always mean you have to be
wackier at all I think the more serious
you take comedy the funnier it is yeah
not everybody can do that's exactly they
don't have that drama but that's what I
learned from that yeah you know so you
material was serious
especially for you guys a lot of the
stand-up material was you know
uncomfortable moments in a good way
well you to let me I remember like my
fondest memory of you on set is we're
like we're at the bar yeah and it was
just like you know we found out clay was
dead
yeah it was like they just go okay cry
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah you had like just
like the whole that's like our you're
just over there I just kept my my scene
was just a look I just I didn't even
have lines in that it was just like in
an even went over to me like we gotta
get we got to get his look and I was
just like yeah that was the big yes yeah
was a great scene yeah Melissa Leo just
behind the bar
that's crazy as she is it was still it
was still a fascinating to be around her
and that's kind of know what it's all
about right yeah I well you what you
would think so I mean that you know the
hard part about when you'd worked on a
show like that it's like it's like
summer camp you know because we're like
oh my god I love you we're gonna be
friends forever we're like talking we
had a we had a group chat remember when
we were you guys took me out of it it
didn't take me actually it took me
longer to realize this great group chat
when all the actors and then everybody
that gets removed from the show we start
a new chat that was out you know who's
funny al Madrigal did that he did it was
he said a new text breeze Garth he knew
you were coming back and we're like all
right moving on I was like weird I guess
they don't hang out anymore just be like
we're talking about the show it was
already pretty out of the loop anyway
honestly it was it was bound to happen
but we we we didn't know I wanted you to
be on the show I thought you were it was
room for you I know there's but it's
like always our question but listen you
went on to bigger and better things
yeah did the Exorcist and I don't think
I would have gotten passage if I didn't
do excesses yeah well yeah cause now you
have a stay in the loop with them yeah
Oh cuz that was on Fox yeah and same
passing directors - OH
that they love you you love you but this
is I mean cuz they what did you think of
The Exorcist
what was that I thought it was amazing
it was another show it was similar to
this genre high stakes kind of create a
crazy crazy big world Geena Davis played
our mom
Davis was your mom ok this is what I
wanted to ask you I'm not okay how is
that because like when you were a young
actress and even a young girl you are
Geena Davis was like you know she was
like you you know and now she's playing
your mom yeah yeah I mean I was a little
star-struck
um she is she's amazing though she's
really tall also which surprised me
she's really really smart and that was
the most surprising thing she's in Mensa
she's super left brained yeah so her
approach to things was more like I yeah
I think I'm probably a little bit more
emotional and she was more technical so
what's interesting to me too is to be
technical as an actress yes how she
approached it yeah like it was very
important where we were in the scene
physically like her a few like don't
touch that glass if you didn't before
like she wanted that just the way her
brain worked um and but that's always
cool I think to see like that's one of
my favorite things about getting to work
with new people is like how what do they
do on set what can I learn from them or
or what can I take away from this oh wow
that's great yeah and there's some and
then you got the passage right after
that yeah which was it was similar the
timeline time dying up here where we had
to wait was like a year and a half
before it was due it was so I was on
hold and it's like soul-sucking
yeah there's no money's coming in no
money's coming in you can't even go
audition for anything and you're just
watching all these things happen and and
that's when your agents calling to you
like there's this great part for you
that you can't do bye
yeah or they're like you want to try
we'll try to convince some and I'm like
I put some pressure on it but sure and
then it's not a desirable I don't think
they look at you like it's a desirable
position to be in right right right
right right
I know exactly what you're saying and
then but then when you started like it
was you know it was just a fantastic
experience right yeah but how's that
that makeup and stuff though is that
like a nightmare it's um I mean it's
three hours really yeah two and a half
three hours the guy Addison is
phenomenal he did it all like hats off
to them because they really that could
really make a break it you know like I
think ya can't stand when like right if
it looks bad you're not gonna watch yeah
yeah that was a problem I'm dying up
here first season we just had these with
ridiculous ways my dad you know it was
okay this was weird
you know I remember from down right here
you punched me I always remember that
too in a scene yeah our first scene
together Shawna's backstory for passage
where we're in the kitchen and I I mean
this is a different kind of scene but
where I go after this stepdad I have to
like I have to physically approach him
and I hit him really hard and any kind
of like and I was like I don't know why
I did yeah I guess so oh yeah I'll give
it back to the make um the makeup come
ask you when you do when you're doing
those makeup scenes is it like that that
whole day is gonna be vampire yeah
exactly so they're called our viral days
where we're just from all viral you bust
them all out and we have the cheekbones
which I really like that kind of that's
what changed the whole face really oh I
don't even notice that yeah we're very
subtle change
we're gaunt oh and then they lay on the
prosthetic veins that are kind of 3d I
love you Instagram by the way you had to
follow her I'll have all that
information on the on the bottom of the
the video but yeah you always have some
great behind-the-scenes shots
those are good I was worried as I got
back into auditioning now that this
shows over I was like [ __ ] are people
gonna look at my Instagram that we can't
I don't want to cast this vampire like
it's all VAM so I'm trying to have some
more variety yeah but then we have you
had a teeth and the veins and then they
hand paint the veins and that's what
takes a long time but makes it look so
real and then the contacts which are
like a quarter like they're really they
cover your whole eye yeah they have
someone come to set to put them in Wow
yeah so there's like do you not look
because I hate it put it on the makeup
in the way
no I am or that day I'm in the morning
boys oh god here we go with just
nonsense I don't mind it you don't mind
it no it's kind of relaxing you don't do
anything you just say hang out Wow
well you know I can say you're great on
the show and I hope it good and I feel
like this is gonna rock it line I'm
gonna make another prediction this is
gonna rock and launch you into like
movies and stuff do you want to do
movies absolutely yeah I see I could see
that like you're a long side like
whoever I just want to be a long side
whoever there's a yuen yuen like you
know you're in the John wick for yeah I
want to do a sequel to something or
you're gonna be in some artsy nonsense
that's gonna be in Sundance and
everybody cool yeah you're gonna be
doing both I mean now what I want
another thing I want to talk to you
about I was like so I know you're in a
relationship how's Doogie my doctor boy
I call him Doogie Howser he's not a
doctor though what is he's a lawyer yeah
he's good he's good he doesn't like the
makeup oh he doesn't that was taught
when I would cold face time him like
just quickly with a surprise if I'm in
full makeup didn't like that yeah
because I bet I put on your thing that
that's what his mother thinks you are
anyway monster yeah nobody's I always I
always I always teased her about this
you know her boyfriend this is still my
celebrity crushes you're still I'm still
holding out you started such a rumor on
set that we were getting married people
were texting oh my god Eric every time
you like go to the trash I'm like oh
this is what he's gonna ask you guys in
you're surprised he's gonna do it I
don't know why he has it like what kind
of idiot would marry this woman already
everyone trying to get married I don't
get it is he do you want to get married
um now that we have been together long
enough now where it does I mean yeah
he's my partner so in that sense yes but
I I have never been that girl he's like
fantasize
like I have no he wanted to go to NYU
and like travel the world becomes like I
don't have those
I just never fantasized about that
there's nothing wrong with it and also I
don't know the majority of my family one
kind of gets divorce no I'm just I'm not
running towards it but I think they can
be a great thing but he's you get me to
get like two years now right three three
and a half we need a happy years from
one negative quality everybody her
boyfriend's like a mole you know now kid
he's a great guy I love that I love your
Instagram and all that now does he he's
a doctor right now
I always a doctor but I love calling him
Doogie Howser yeah cuz he's like he's
good he's like a cute young face dude I
guess so he looks like he's 11 you know
he's a good-looking guy obviously the
premiere yes yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah so but like how is he about like
you know you're the love scenes and
you're kissing guys all the time it's
funny about it he's super chill like
he's definitely my foil I feel like I'm
more energetic and have a lot going on
and he's like calm cool collected
yeah but so during like the kissing
scenes he gets all riled up and I like
that oh yes finally it affects him yeah
you're the worst you love getting you so
did you see my I'm surprised he doesn't
like interrogate you like a lawyer how
many takes were there number base
question you like yeah well we practice
like ten times the day before he doesn't
really care that's good good forgot
so he's securing himself yeah definitely
this whole thing no he's just super
supportive that's great that he's a
keeper
like after three years you know cuz I
could because it would be terrible to be
with somebody that's like you know he's
like you kissing that [ __ ] again
yeah wouldn't working out in Hollywood
you know I mean that's good easier does
it does grandma like him she does she
does thank God
it's just funny to think about your
grandma on him like like like like
talking about your vampire stuff like
she really hates it like an exorcist was
honestly worse than this because that's
like sacrilegious oh that was like the
worst thing I could have done cuz you
went to Catholic schools your whole
family's like staunch Catholics mm more
dis grandma but every we know Oh where's
grandma from originally where you
worship family from they are I mean way
way back with German Irish Oh German
Irish yes how does that even work
what do you mean the Germans do anything
bad today Irish I can't yeah but when
you're when you're like invoking the
German part of you and that when you're
I did 23 no it's cool you did too what
were the results I mean it was I'm 100
percent white
so no surprise there was grandma happy
about that and I'm primarily I'm like a
more Scandinavian than I thought and
more French than I thought but primarily
German Irish Wow just 100% European but
it does cool things like it'll tell you
like if you're more likely to have
freckles or not or in town yeah actually
I don't want to do it no because then
they have you're just I don't want to
know you know it's a week who's like
that's like I've identified myself and
like for so long it's like a mixed-race
this than that then she like actually no
you put yourself in this box of like oh
now I can only talk about these things
or whatnot you know and I just don't
want to do that okay you know I don't
that but I've heard some like crazy I
knew a lady she was telling me about so
she found out that she was like British
and something else okay
and then her parents weren't that like
one of her parents wasn't that
so that's when she went to them like hey
tell me you yeah turns out no it turns
out that it was it was the it wasn't her
real mom you know and then that led to
her realizing realizing all this
resentment that they had for each other
over the years was stemmed from that so
her trying to be a good mom but still
being like you ain't my kid energy so
that's what that revealed you know so in
that case I think it's good because then
you have like a you know how I know why
this has been like the whole time so you
only child brothers and sisters I have
four younger siblings yeah and three of
them are half so my sister Kailyn is 23
the horse you're talking about yes but
she is a fine 23 she's your half-sister
that's my horses that's your sister so
she's my daughter all jokes everybody
don't we don't want any here I see you
have okay then both my parents remarried
and had more I'm so my yeah my dad's
kids are now 14 and 16 and they are half
Vietnamese my stepmoms Vietnamese Oh
Arkadia wow yeah that's so crazy sure
they're so proud have they Condorcet had
any of your family guy gone to set with
you i never shoot at home oh that's why
you guys are in atlanta yeah
oh wow oh yeah cuz all that outdoorsy
[ __ ] do you yeah and the tax breaks I
guess like I don't know why California
will get their [ __ ] together and just do
that I'm doing I'm recurring on doll
face which is here and that's like the
first show and since I'm dying up here
how they get California though is
because I think you know a reason why
I'm dying up here was able to shoot in
California to get that they had a
lottery for like the tax break it's an
actual lottery yeah yes like some kind
of yeah I think they I think it's a
random selection I don't know how they
decide actually I don't know how it
really works but I know that not a lot
of shows got that but I'm dying up here
was one of the shows that got like a
huge tax break okay so that so now you
know Lent Hollywood South everybody Lana
to do stuff yeah how was that living out
there it's all right have you been there
I've been there yeah I hate the weather
see the freezing or yeah and we were
there from August to December so it was
all of it it's pretty and the food is
great but I don't know after a few weeks
you're kind of like okay what did Doogie
go with you yeah he came out twice and
then I would come home okay I mean you
could only it's only it's four months
it's not like horrible but yeah it's
still horrible it's a long time yeah
that's like a long-distance relationship
it's all I mean the last three years
I've been our first year we were
together I was out of town nine months
oh wow I was in London and during that
time yeah oh my god so you actually
actually have only been together like 11
months right 11 month relationship like
five years would be like I don't live
here no that's so hilarious let me see
what we're we had on time oh wow how
much how much time we've been going here
perfect you didn't even think you could
do it look at yeah that was this is so
fun yeah you were like so what do you
what are you watching right now other
than like watching the passes when you
live tweet am i watch what's your what's
your jam right now I mean reality TV we
did watch bachelor last night I have the
viewing parties with my girlfriends my
comedy Sportz girlfriend really you
watch The Bachelor yeah it's more out of
tradition God I watched The Bachelor and
parent you know who I watched a bachelor
in paradise with yeah Mike Mike Arianna
and his family please like I went over
there one time and I'm talk
smack and then all of a sudden I'm like
pause it isn't I can't believe you know
that I got into it yeah it's it's a
community experience like I wouldn't
watch alone because that would be no fun
I'm gonna have to watch I'm a big
brother guy Oh see I've never done that
oh my god I love Big Brother okay good
it's like a psychological experiment
like it brings out the worst in people
like they have to be monsters to be on
that show yeah cuz you're like you're
backstabbing and and and then you have
to like you know make alliances and then
go back on those alliances and then lie
to people it's like Game of Thrones
it's very Game of Thrones yeah which I
love trailers are you ready for the new
game yeah I'm excited
you know you're on a good show and you
can wait that long in between seasons
yeah how long is that I don't know I
hear it's terrible to be on Game of
Thrones though like yeah because you're
on hold for like nine months or whatever
they film all over the world and the
West world takes forever
oh you watching true detective I didn't
see the new season but I like my first
season second season wasn't a fan of I'm
like I'm getting to the new season it's
good but I wasn't a West world guy you
really liked what I did yeah Wow I
couldn't I just appreciated it it was
fun to watch I just thought it was like
I thought it was like boring terminator
really yeah you know what I mean like
it's like emo robots yeah I thought it
was like you mean to tell me you can't
just reset these damn robots you can't
just you can't just wipe this hard drive
and start over with at least turn on us
yeah emo Terminator yeah what are you
watching
I like I like the passage I like those I
like you know my favorite show for like
Network show was how to get away with
murder
really oh my god yeah so I don't know
his character name Oh Jack fella he I
don't know if he's gay on the show or bi
but I think oh how to make a on the show
yeah but it's so good like they they
find ways to like keep heightening the
station
yes she's great yeah I don't like this
you went over to Netflix that just takes
away from actors
making money right you know like that's
what I don't understand like you know
it's like there's no way to get rid
there's no real residuals it's just
buyouts yeah it's like they're ruining
the ruining in the game what are we
gonna do I somewhat something's gonna
have to happen yeah you know can't be
career if you can't make money yeah you
know so I hopefully they're gonna come
in the unions talking about striking
right now anyways yeah are you are you
involved with that kind of stuff at all
hmm are the actors yeah I don't know I
mean I know I feel like most of the
strikes have been writer's strike so far
I don't know I start thing coming up I
don't know because I feel like we should
be fighting for different exclusivity
like I don't think it should be you I
don't think we should be fighting for
hey there's only ten episodes are you
locking my life up for a year and a half
yeah that's right I know we we sign
everything away I think we don't really
like when we're sitting there testing I
know
sign your you just sign your whole life
before you even have the part it's still
first world problems sorry guys it's
actor problem something people people
are listening like oh you made all that
money but still it's all relative yeah
but I want to work one it's a muscle it
doesn't feel good to not like you know
you have to go back to set and you
haven't worked in months isn't a great
feeling yeah yeah it's not a great
feeling
so once the passage once you find that
you don't know if the passage is coming
back or not no I think we'll know in may
you're gonna know I may I said were just
like they said they made a big
announcement that they were like we are
not doing any early pickups so don't
even ask us about it and we were like
but really didn't I feel like it's gonna
come back I do think it's gonna come
back but if it doesn't come back I still
feel like you're gonna work for the rest
of your life well thank you you know I
really do like what you're doing on the
show I just think it's like you know cuz
what I like that's what I like about you
know like I like the walking dead you
know but cuz it's like I need that like
monster dramatic ratio to be yeah and I
think the passage has a good ratio for
those you know so it's like you know all
the things it's like doing it's not just
it's not right
I think it could just be that you know
it could have been anything it didn't
have to be in fact exactly it's not a
vampire vampire
it's about the relationships between all
the characters yes and like I said a
little girl is great everybody doesn't
really never watch them be like we have
a great cast we're gonna like you watch
bloodline I did watch bloodline Jamie
did bloodline Fanning who's like the oh
yes everyone is just I look forward to
working with all of them yes I but again
I gotta tell you I am always scared when
you're honest really yeah because like
because they do this trick where when
it's like you're in his head they they
changed a lighting yeah all the cult
vibes was very important yeah they
changed the lighting it's like it's very
much like and you're just a creepy ass
yeah creepy ass chick man I just feel
like like there's a lot of stillness
which we learned kind of was creepier
than trying to be chaotic oh yeah this
stillness is a little terrifying oh
here's a great terrifying scene it is so
silly but it was like I was like ooh
that's creepy
it's like he's everybody celebrating you
know Oh everybody celebrating anything
like and you just know you're sitting
there having a beer with the officers
yes and he saw and he saw he sees you
and he's just like you know but that
guy's a ruggedly handsome guy you have a
lot of he's on a look at Boardwalk
Empire oh yeah he was Lucky Luciano oh
yes great that's what I'm saying like I
have watched all of these shows and was
just so excited to get to work with
don't worry people are gonna be excited
to work with you - you're the you're
right there you're you're gonna be
you're a star you're a star cuz you're
like you're a big part of that show I
could tell like they're not gonna just
kill you off I'm also immortal look at
that what okay
no I know anything this is just one one
shot to the heart uh I think we did at
some point yeah they use a fancier word
though for the heart oh there's
something that's really charged with the
sweets but it is yes for the acai
there's a lot of jargon yeah
yeah yeah it's very it's very like yeah
no that's good you're with it like you
can kind of does it confuse you
no but I I don't know I I just like it I
guess part of me is like because I know
you so it's like you know it how about
let me at lattice let's talk about this
before we leave it's like you know a lot
of actors and actresses you have friends
you know and it's like you want them to
be on something good of course you know
because it's just like a nightmare where
they're not it's more fun for all of us
yeah I've had people be I'm like oh my
god they're like my buddy Chris D'Elia
he was on Whitney right you know it was
just it just it didn't work out in the
end it wasn't believable these two
attractive people or not anyway right
but you know you I'll have a lot of fans
that have been on sitcoms where I've
been like oh is that a nightmare you
know so this is one where I just enjoy
watching it so good so other than
grandma's gonna figure it out yeah it's
yeah but have you had like a Fred you
know something where you like they were
like hey did you see it how was this and
you were like like I'm getting there
like my podcast that's different I I
know the podcast world is tricking out
too because it's always a tricky because
there's I'm in the middle of a game why
are you at your three-hour makeup you
could be yeah I did we used to do that I
used to put them on um
I know now because now I'm riffing with
Griffin you know what that's a great way
to anyways guys thanks for watching
ripping with Griffin and please look out
for the beautiful the talented the
gorgeous the vixen she's done it all
she's gonna do more Dookie marry this
woman Dookie he's gonna he's gonna see
this that he's gonna be like I love him
too he's a great dude what's his real
name again Matt yeah well you can't call
him Doogie uh
Doogie the lawyer but I do thank you for
coming on thank you so much
no and I told you we're gonna have a
good time she's just so run I've never
done one before I don't think really
yeah you so used to do in your passage
press was like now you're here like you
know this is like we just having a good
conversation but but thanks for coming
on Christ hey guys this has been riffing
with Griffin and tonight cuz I'm putting
this one out tonight please watch well
actually if people stay on it's like it
doesn't matter but if you if you watched
it for the first time the podcast
tonight watched a passage season finale
to our season finale and if you've
watched this podcast later go back and
watch on Hulu watched a passage it's a
great show breanne Howie thank you for
coming